so someone on my podcast asked a
question how many eggs can I eat per day
okay
so the first thing I want to talk about
is when you actually buy eggs you'll see
them in many different labels and
packages cage free eggs or free-range or
natural eggs or eggs fed vegetarian feed
this really means nothing because Kate
free means they're outside of the Kate
but they're still in the barn
free-range again the definition is very
limited who knows what that means
natural there's no real legal definition
of what natural means I mean what would
be not like an artificial egg I don't
understand that and then we have
vegetarian feed which only tells you is
that you could feed soybeans and corn
which are both GMO we don't want that we
want pasture raised okay pasture raised
has a definition of out in the pasture
when the grass that's where we want them
living and eating grass and bugs and
things like that and we definitely want
organic on top of that so we want
organic and pasture raised not
pasteurized okay we want pasture raised
now the cool thing about eggs is they
have a lot of nutrition tons of fat
soluble vitamins vitamin A amazing
amounts of vitamin A vitamin k2 vitamin
E omega-3 fatty acids high-quality
protein it's like it's like a complete
perfect food it has B vitamins the only
vitamin it doesn't have is vitamin C and
that's why we need to eat other things
too like salads and things like that
it even has lutein ins and
very powerful phytonutrients or
antioxidants specifically to repair the
any potential damage that occurs in the
artery walls or the eyes and so if we
have a repair action right here the
cholesterol and the eggs are not going
to accumulate so even though eggs have
cholesterol your body makes cholesterol
a lot like 3,000 milligrams so when you
eat more your body makes less and you're
going to actually have higher amounts of
good cholesterol as well
so having more cholesterol is not going
to be damaging especially if you have
the antioxidants to protect the wall of
the arteries because the problem has
never been cholesterol in the first
place
the problem is oxidative damage on the
artery wall which then the cholesterol
comes as a band-aid to heal it okay cost
role has never been the villain
cholesterol is needed to support brain
and nerve function and all the cell
walls cholesterol is needed to make bile
and vitamin D cholesterol is needed to
make hormones so there are more problems
with low cholesterol than there is high
cholesterol so how many eggs can you eat
per day as many as you want I have four
eggs every day you can have more you
could have ten eggs a day it's not going
to be a problem thanks for watching so I
hope you're coming to the keto Health
Summit coming up in October so I want to
quickly comment on what we're gonna do
that's different from other conventions
okay the problem with these other
conventions is they give you information
over a load okay it's so much data that
you're basically swimming in a sea of
information we're going to do things
very differently we're only going to
cover the most important things that
make a huge difference now there are
three very powerful strategies that
we're going to be talking about at the
summit that you will not find at any of
my youtube videos number one is on
memory I'm going to be showing you
something very cool to dramatically
increase your memory and concentration
that's going to blow you away and number
two I'm going to show you how to
increase your stress tolerance so you
are completely calm all the time alright
and number three and most importantly if
you have a slow metabolism
if you've died it for a long time and
everything is kind of just really slow
I'm going to show you how to get
complete control over your metabolism so
you can literally turn up the dial as
high as you want and control as much
weight as you want to lose and these
three things are just a tiny bit of what
you're going to learn in the summit so
click the link below get signed up and I
will see you in October